anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir alors est-ce que le charbo vous
convaincre luc ferrandez convient que
vous faisiez le plus critique 28 oh j'ai
ouï oui il nous convient parce que ce
qui nous dit c'est moi j'en un modèle
d'affaires à notre modèle d'affaires
c'est prendre le moins de risques
possible d'arriver dans les délais
pression se finance sur s'entend avec 8
% de retour son investissement 60
modèles d'affaires avec ce modèle
d'affaires là on ne veut pas prendre ce
genre de risque maintenant techniquement
serré cela ils peuvent se prendre ils se
sont pris très souvent à montréal
l'hôtel bonaventure et construit on
n'accorde qu'une métro sous l'hôtel
bonaventure après qu'on ait construit
des hôtels et c'est entre une autoroute
et un hôtel et une gare de train qui
rentrent dans l'hôtel bonaventure en
même temps c'est possible le carré viger
qui vient d'être rénové sous le carré
viger via la ligne orange qui passe et
il y à une autoroute est ce le carré
viger a été rénové ça a été fait c'est
compliqué il faut mais des sismographes
fausse aperçu faut s'assurer qu'il n'y a
pas de problème vous continuez le cas
dire je peux suggère dans quelle mesure
j'ai pu lire toutes les résumés des
chaînes qui ont été déposées mais vous
continuez à dire
s'arrêter c'est encore possible un
tunnel sur toute la longueur au
centre-ville bien sûr que c'est possible
c'est tout à fait possible mais mais ça
aurait un impact sur les coûts y'a aucun
entrepreneur qui voudraient rentrer dans
ce projet là avec une avec l'obligation
de payer lui-même des délais et des
coûts supplémentaires ça c'est vrai mais
c'est peut-être c'est à cause de la
formule de ces des picots et comme si
tout faire
non mais regardez dans le claf razer on
a dépensé 2 2 milliards de dollars le
coût de ce projet on l'a dépassée de
deux ans aussi de coût du projet alors
lorsqu'on dit c'est dans la phase de
11,0 des plats dépassements de coûts et
0 dépassement de délais et pzero risque
c'est sûr qu'avec ces trois rôles à une
faute face à l'aérien avec un petit bout
quand même à 10 ans sur la caisse fait
un petit bout dans le sous-sol 500 m
pour faire une station qui veut
raccorder avec le montréal souterrain
bon là ils disent maintenant que c'est
possible dans cette partie là est ce que
ça vous a convaincu vous ce plaidoyer
mais moi moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est la
transparence rappelons nous de la
semaine dernière on en parlait poursuivi
attendant d'avoir les études pour se
positionner je pense qu'ils étaient
clairs oui oui le tout est possible à
quel coût à quels risques et est ce que
le projet robosphère c'est la question
qu'on doit se poser actuellement nous
ont montré qu'ils ont prouvé parce que
moi je pourrais génial ingénieur ils ont
prouvé moi j'ai lu le rapport cet après
midi que c'est pas possible c'est trop
risqué de le faire comme on voulait le
faire est la seule partie qui était
possible beaucoup moins de troubles
c'était la partie qui nous ont présenté
aujourd'hui donc il ya une partie qui
est possible de le faire dans certains
coups on ne sait pas encore ce c'est la
prochaine étape combien ça va coûter
aujourd'hui nous disent ok ce scénario
souterrain qui ne sont pas bons il y en
a un qu'on retient c'est le dernier
celle de compagnies espagnoles que que
fait la proposition de le tunnel qui est
là mais on sait pas encore combien ça va
coûter on ne sait pas encore cette
partie là mais c'est possible oui de
faire une partie du tunnel sans prendre
les risques parce que même si on décide
d'aller avec les autres structures même
son époux ingénieur ni toi ni moi lutte
on sait pas si une compagnie qui va
prendre le risque de le faire il ya tous
ceux aussi don royal et où c'est
possible puis la possibilité qui est là
c'est celle qui est sur la table pour
l'instant mais c'est pas encore à cet
accord il vaut lui tire dans le temps il
y aura des il y aura une consultation y
aura le dépôt de l'architecturé la
structure puis après ça va y avoir la
balle on est on est loin de la coupe aux
lèvres le début d'un début donc luc c
est ce qu est ce que le le mieux n'est
pas l'ennemi du bien dans ce projet là
c'est qu'à force de vouloir toujours
quelque chose de magnifique
d'extraordinaire de de prairies oui je
comprends très bien votre question je
comprends très bien là mais la laideur
comme la beauté ce sont des cumuls le
cumul qui mène à la laideur ultime de
temps exemple dans une structure
aérienne de sousse et ombragé elle est
couverte de tags lieu du vin les
commerces ferment au rez-de-chaussée ya
déjà que s'installe avec détente dessous
et ça c'est arrivé à kensington cuite en
à philadelphie c'est arrivé à chicago
c'est des choses qui sont possibles la
caisse peut pas nous garantir ce qui va
se passer dans 20 ans et par une crise
économique plus d'itinérants l'espère
vont s'installer là dans la partie qui
descendent par exemple pour aller au
centre-ville c'est un fuji parfait c'est
un abri parfait pour des étudiants est
ce qu'on va grillagée cette partie là
des détails qui comptent la caisse ne
peut pas garantir pour les 10 15 20 ou
30 prochaines années sont enrichis
sherbrooke dans la liesse est ce que ça
vaut faire d'évaluer tellement les
commerces au rez-de-chaussée qu'ils vont
fermer c'est arrivé dans plein de villes
dans le monde alors la laideur est un
cumul de petites choses la caisse mais
les premiers éléments mais peut-être
d'autres et les membres et la beauté
aussi c'est un cumul exécute un jour ou
l'autre
chose c'est moi le côté noir moi parce
que je reste à côté du métropolitain
mais je vois dans le monde des gens qui
sont qui ont des bonnes idées pam à
shanghai en tour de la métropolitaine où
il met des bacs à fleurs sur le bord de
l'autoroute en bon ils font des
garderies pour enfin lyon du tpiy
vaillons des magasins de fruits il ya
plein de choses qu'on peut façon le
capot le bord du terrain c'est sûr qu'un
ado qui vont l'occuper donc le défi
c'est ça c'est comment on est capable
trouver un projet imaginaire je ne
compte plus quand il a réalisé un bond à
nice et super besse mais la casse parce
que la caisse nous propose ici un rôle à
jouer oui c'est chaque vont se
positionner madame plan monsieur coderre
face à ce qu'on vient d'apprendre
aujourd'hui d'après vous rapidement le
qui ça c'est très intéressant parce que
madame colère madame plante
souvent les ombrages mais madame plante
a laissé le vote libre alors à la sam et
risma caroline bourgeois de rivière des
prairies pointe aux trembles qui est
pour et qui fait des sorties pour et il
ya le maire d'hochelaga maisonneuve
bercy qui a fait une sortie contre alors
c'est très intéressant
ce sera aux citoyens de décider parce
qu'évidemment ça va devenir une décision
électorale parce que les deux sont en
élection donc les apports répondu tout
de suite très sagement pour voir comment
les gens étaient pour réagir donc demain
on aura certainement ce leurs réactions
merci beaucoup 1 et l'udc à très bientôt